TRACY FREY: Hi, everybody.
Welcome to "Responsible AI--
From Theory to Practice."
my name is Tracy Frey.
And I'm the Director of
Product Strategy and Operations
for Cloud AI and
Industry Solutions.
To start us off, I want to
root us all in this statement.
In less than 10 years,
AI will be the number one
driver of global GDP growth.
This graph shows that growth
through 2030, $13 trillion.
And not only that,
organizations that
achieve AI absorption
will be the leaders
of the global
economy in that time.
That growth has already started.
People around the world have
become everyday AI users.
And soon, technology
that isn't AI-enabled
will feel like
something is missing.
Think of technologies that
we didn't have 10 years ago--
direct payment applications like
Venmo, virtual home assistance.
Our reliance on AI
has already begun.
And it will only
become more pronounced.
Prior to 2012, AI
results closely
tracked Moore's law,
with compute doubling
every two years.
Post-2012, compute has been
doubling every 3.4 months.
For example, vision AI has
gotten more accurate and more
powerful.
Take a look at the
error rate progression
here from 2011 to 2020.
While this is undoubtedly
good news for innovation,
it also requires more care and
attention from a responsibility
standpoint.
A more accurate and powerful
vision AI technology,
when used in a
harmful way, can lead
to harmful and intentional
misuse, unintentional failure
modes, loss of personal
privacy, contributing
to severe real life
consequences for individuals,
all at incredible
speed and scale.
CCS Insights reports
that trusting AI systems,
just like the vision AI, is the
biggest barrier to adoption,
moving from the lab to
production for enterprises.
There is a perception
that there is broadly
a deficit in the areas
of ethical diligence
over these powerful
technologies.
We hear a lot of questions
on Responsible AI
once organizations
start to think
about moving to production.
And Responsible AI is
impacting adoption.
And as a team, we are seeing
more and more companies
come to us asking
for help because they
are facing challenges.
There is a lack of trust in
the AI systems themselves.
And when ethical issues arise,
which 90% of organizations
have encountered,
40% of companies
abandon instead of
solving for those issues.
These numbers show a huge risk
in not taking responsibility
into consideration.
It's not possible
for any technology
to be morally or values-neutral.
Values are interpolated at
every stage of AI development.
And each technology
is developed in order
to do something, which
expresses a value decision.
That reveals a huge
barrier to AI adoption.
And it's a key driver.
One study found these
reasons for ethical issues
within organizations.
Governance is reported to
be the biggest enterprise
requirement in AI in 2020.
Not only will enterprises
embrace governance,
we can expect
increasing legislation,
potential regulatory issues.
And consumers will begin to
judge and select organizations
based on these policies.
Gartner reports
that, as consumers
become more aware and savvy
about how organizations are
using their data, and
organizations are using
increasing amounts of AI and
ML to drive business decisions,
enterprises must embrace
ideas like explainable AI
and transparent data policies
for both ethical and business
reasons.
Customers will begin to judge
and select organizations
based on these policies.
By 2020, Gartner
expects companies
that are digitally
trustworthy will
generate 20% more online
profit than those who are not.
This all fits into
our belief at Google
that responsible AI
equals successful AI.
We recognize that
the decisions we make
and the way we
develop technology
will have a lasting impact
The efficiency gains
and competitive advantage are
only going to be fully realized
in a world where AI is
responsibly developed
and trusted by end users.
If anywhere trust
gets broken, we
will see guy
getting pulled back.
So to us, responsibly AI
really leads to successful AI.
To build responsible
AI into our DNA,
we began asking ourselves
a few questions.
This is rooted in the idea
that people and businesses
with the best of
intentions can potentially
cause unintended harm.
And we need to
understand the risks
and build out processes
to avoid those outcomes.
For us at Google,
as you might relate,
we feel an immense
responsibility
to develop systems to answer
these critical questions
and build in the proper
principles, practices,
and programs in support of
responsible AI development,
to ensure that AI we build
and enable for the world
is successful.
While we've come a long way,
this work is never finished.
It is far from perfected.
And we approach this
work from a humble place.
We are constantly
iterating and assessing
our work and progress,
but don't pretend
to have all of the answers.
Our goal today is to
share with you how
we've approached building
responsibility in by design
into our products, but more
importantly our organization
to support the necessary
inquiry, deliberation,
and culture to build products
aligned with our values.
We'll focus mainly
on Google Cloud
because that's where we
sit, and because it's
arguably one of the more
complex areas to align.
We have a range of general
purpose tools like auto-MLs
and APIs, all the
way to solutions
that go much farther up the
stack, like Contact Center AI.
The way these
technologies can be used
can be quite varied
and hard to predict,
which makes it a good place
to discuss putting principles
into practice.
What grounds our approach
to responsible AI at Google
are our AI principles.
Ethical AI, responsible AI,
and all of the associated terms
can feel amorphous or nebulous.
How do you begin to wrangle
all of the often contradictory
ethical theories and critical
components of AI responsibility
into a systematic way to apply
them to your development?
For us, as for many
organizations now,
we found that the most
important first step
was developing our
company-wide AI principles
in the summer of 2017.
So in 2018, we published
our AI principles.
These are not just a
marketing campaign for us.
They are the constitution we
use to build our AI products,
conduct research, and
draft our policies.
Our set of AI
principles has been
one of the most important
things we have implemented.
They keep us motivated
by a common purpose--
succinctly
communicate our values
in developing advanced
technology for the world
and ensure that the way we
use artificial intelligence
is in the best
interest of humanity.
We believe that organizations
and communities flourish
best when, in addition to our
own personal ethical values,
there are also shared
ethical commitments
within the community
that each person can play
a part in fulfilling, so that
our work is more about doing
something good together, not
doing whatever we privately
think is best and just
assuming or hoping
that others' values and choices
will magically mirror our own.
But as we know, a plan on
paper, like these principles
and practices, are
only effective if they
are operationalized.
Looking at a list of
principles like ours
can be hard to incorporate
into our day-to-day work
as we deal with detailed
engagements of our products.
What remains true is that our
AI principles aren't magic.
They don't immediately
answer all of our questions
on how to move forward.
They don't relinquish us from
having hard conversations.
They are a starting point in
establishing what we stand for
and what we can agree
to build toward.
The work that has ensued
beyond the publication
of the principles has been
to interpret and apply them
in practice.
At the end of the
day, if something
goes wrong with the technology,
and you have principles
like ours, and you can't prove
what you did to prevent that,
then that is a terrible outcome.
We realized very
quickly that, in order
to be true to the
principles, we needed
to develop internal
governance processes that
put our principles into practice
in a systematic and repeatable
way.
This includes building
responsible AI governance
capacity in the form of product
and customer deal review
committees, educational
programs, a partner program,
and trainings in how we consult
and work with our customers.
We'll touch on each of these.
Beginning with Google's
AI review processes,
the original hope was
that the principles
would be a decision guide.
But in reality, they
can't because the company
has such a wide variety
of the ways it uses AI.
The reality is that you can
take any baseline technology,
and it can be beneficial
when used in one way
and harmful in another.
So governing AI is not
only about the technology,
but it's the combination
of the technology, the use
case, the training data, the
societal context in which it
operates, and how it's
deployed in production.
There is no world where blanket
statements can hold water
if you're going to
align the principles.
And it requires that
people in the organization
are committed to the complexity.
So we've built a
Google-wide ecosystem
around how we operationalize.
We have a central
Google function
that consists of
a senior executive
council, which is supported by
responsible innovation team.
That team is
charted with helping
teams around Google
in every product area
learn to operationalize the
principles for themselves.
When we in Cloud
initially thought
about how to begin putting our
AI principles into practice--
and this happened before the
principles were published--
our first instinct, like
many, is that all we had to do
was create a big decision tree
and a checklist for what's OK
and what's not based on the
principles we established.
Our AI principles are
intentionally broad.
And Google is a let 1,000
flowers bloom kind of place.
And we have so much breadth in
the various product offerings
that it would be impossible to
have a checklist or decision
tree at the level of detail
that everyone would agree with.
And I guarantee you that's
the case for you as well.
Checklists feel
comforting, but in practice
have been ineffective at
addressing governance processes
for such nascent technologies.
In order to provide
rigorous evaluations
but flexibly allow for the new
technologies to take shape,
in Google Cloud, we've
created two separate review
bodies that are connected
but purposely distinct.
The first review body
covers early stage customer
engagements, where
we are engaging
in custom AI or
advanced technology
with a customer or partner.
This group is a
decision making group.
And it is very high throughput.
And its intention is to
very quickly give an answer
to the field team as to whether
a project can move forward,
is not aligned with principles
and won't move forward,
or if it will move forward
with some conditions.
We've seen a range of those
decisions over the 2+ years
that we've been doing this.
The next half of the process
is how we build and develop
our products.
When it comes to the AI
products we develop at Google,
we undertake rigorous and
deep ethical analysis, risk,
and opportunity assessments
across each principle.
And we create
alignment proposals
that we bring to those
reviews, where we often
have very uncomfortable but
extraordinarily inspiring
conversations.
With a healthy product pipeline,
we aim for in-depth reviews
every two weeks relatively early
on in the product development
lifecycle, which is essential.
In advance of the review
meeting, a member of the team
takes on the task of doing
an initial evaluation
of the product,
working hand-in-hand
with the technical teams
to understand the product
in-depth, in order to assess
the principles implications
and recommend
mitigations to build
into the plans for the product.
This document serves as the
basis for the discussion
come review time.
This meeting of the minds is
one of the most important steps
in any principles evaluation
to allow us to do two things--
issue spot as a team, and
come to outcomes and paths
forward for products that
are not just good in theory,
but are able to be
actualized in practice.
Over time, these
conversations have
been effective at
normalizing conversations
about risky technology and
potentially adverse outcomes
that we can then prevent.
The next question, I'm
sure you're wondering,
is, what do those paths
forward look like?
The paths forward can look
like a lot of different things.
It can be that we
more narrowly scope
the purpose of the technology.
In some cases, this can
mean we make a decision
not to launch a product
as a general purpose API
or without an allow list.
As you may have seen,
we decided in 2018
that we wouldn't make
facial recognition
available as a
general purpose API.
Even though the
technology exists,
we won't make it available
for anyone to use.
And we found a path
forward for the technology
by scoping it to a narrow
celebrity recognition offering,
which we'll talk about in a bit.
Other mitigations can
look like identifying
educational materials
or best practices
to package up with a
product and launch it.
This has taken the shape
of launching the product
with the associated model
card, a project we took on
to organize the essential facts
of a machine learning model
in a structured
way, or launching
more specific implementation
guides like our inclusive ML
guide embedded in
our product UIs.
From there, we create
an alignment plan
with the mitigations discussed
in the meeting, which
then goes through signoff by
our product and engineering
leadership.
It's key to note that
not all paths forward
involve tech solutions or fixes
because ethics problems are not
always the result of
technology lapses,
but are actually more a
product of the societal context
in which it's being deployed
and how it's used as intended.
Over time, through
this review process,
we identify patterns similar to
case law, where we are creating
a growing set of precedents
and best practices
on sensitive topics to inform
decisions and drive consistency
on whether a new product
can go ahead and with what
mitigations.
There is no one size
fits all approach.
Flexibility is important.
And it's not just
a point in time.
As that societal
context changes,
then we have to
respond differently
as we make our
decisions going forward.
Here are some of the
imperatives and challenges
we've learned over
those past two years.
One thing that I
really want to stress
is the importance of a
diverse review committee.
Members are intentionally
multi-level.
We have folks who are just
starting their careers out
of college all the
way up through VPs.
We're drawing on
a range of experts
from a diversity of
backgrounds, both technical and
non-technical.
Multiple team members,
including myself,
have deep social
science, and philosophy,
and ethics backgrounds.
And we are really intending
to be cross-functional
across every role that exists
at Google, for the most part,
and that we are not just drawing
from people within Cloud,
but that we are drawing from
expertise across Google.
For each review, we also seek
out additional expertise,
whether that be on
issues of machine
learning fairness and
robustness, or ethical AI,
or a particular use case
or technology, or domain,
or industry.
We're really lucky
that, at Google, we
have a lot of that
expertise in-house.
And when we don't have it in our
walls, we seek it externally.
One of the other most important
things we did in the beginning
is we had the great
opportunity to hire a visiting
researcher, Shannon Fowler, who
was a tech ethicist and world
renowned.
And she worked with us to
help us build this process
and engage in our
reviews in a way that
was incredibly useful for us.
So what we've learned--
we've learned that
constitutions,
like our AI principles,
require interpretation.
Predicting misuse helps
develop guardrails.
This requires us to
imagine what if and explore
all the possible scenarios
and areas of misuse
in order to develop
a comprehensive set
of guardrails.
Our principles aren't magic.
They don't answer
the tough questions.
They're a framework for
those conversations.
Deliberation and healthy
disagreement is key.
We do not hold our
team as an ivory tower
full of moral heroes, but
working collaboratively
within our technical teams
to service potential issues
and remediate them together.
Ethical AI is not only
about the extremes.
And it's not always
about AI for social good.
And it shouldn't be.
Every AI product, regardless
of how innocuous it may seem,
should be put through
principles evaluations.
Here are some of the
trainings we offer Googlers
to build responsibly
AI into our culture
and equip teams with
the tools and knowledge
to insert responsible AI
into their day-to-day work.
Some of these are available
externally as well.
Our aim is to connect
and collaborate
with partners
across the industry.
We want to share our
learnings, learn,
hear fresh and
varied perspectives,
and advance our
collective thinking when
it comes to responsible AI.
The final way in which we put
our principles into practice
is through a growing
set of tools.
Responsible AI
tools and frameworks
are becoming an increasingly
important and effective way
to explain and
understand our AI models.
Tools get at the
questions, how do I
understand the
predictions made by AI?
How do I know if my data,
or model, or outcomes
have unfair bias?
And how do I know
what is influencing
my model's predictions?
Building tools
and infrastructure
to evaluate and improve
concerns at scale--
today, we'll touch
on four tools we
offer that get at some of the
main concerns facing AI today--
fairness indicators,
what-if tool, model cards,
and explainable AI.
We often get asked
about debiasing models
and how we Google think
about ML fairness.
Broadly speaking, there
is no standard definition
of fairness, whether
decisions are being
made by humans or machines.
Identifying appropriate
fairness criteria for a system
requires accounting for user
experience, cultural, social,
historical, political, legal,
and ethical considerations,
several of which
may have trade-offs.
I also want to stress that there
is no future in which we will
be able to say, in my opinion,
that we have achieved fairness,
that we can say we're done with
this work and we can move on.
This is something that we
engage in for the long term.
And we are always learning
more and evolving.
And we'll show you some
examples of that in a bit.
So why does Google care
about these problems?
Well, our users are diverse.
And it's important
that we provide
an experience that works equally
well across all of our users.
The good news is that
we have the power
to approach these
problems differently
and to create technology
that is fairer and more
inclusive for more people.
We'll start with an
overview of what that means.
And I should also
say that this is
an area we are still learning
about and always will be.
Addressing fairness in
AI is an active area
of research at Google
and beyond from fostering
a diverse workforce that
embodies critical knowledge,
from training models to remove
incorrect problematic biases.
Knowing that there is no
standard definition of fairness
presents both an
opportunity and a challenge.
One thing that I also think
is really important that we've
built into our review process
is a clear recognition
that we may not,
in our group, have
the appropriate lived
experience that can help
inform how we build a product.
We'll show you some
examples of this in a bit.
But it's important
that we recognize--
and that I recognize and
stress, for our team, that we
are coming from a place
of great privilege
and to honor that
as much as we can.
This requires creating
a space that is
rich with psychological safety.
And I cannot stress enough the
importance of doing that work.
An important step
on this path is
acknowledging that humans are
at the center of technology
design, in addition to
being impacted by it.
And humans have not always
made product design decisions
that are in line with
the needs of everyone.
Until 2011, automobile
manufacturers
were not required to use
crash test dummies that
represented female bodies.
As a result, women were 47% more
likely to be seriously injured
in a car accident than men.
Bandaids have long been
manufactured in a single color,
a soft pink, my skin tone.
In this tweet, you see
the personal experience
of an individual using a
Bandaid that matches his skin
tone for the first time.
I will never forget.
I had a third grade
assembly where somebody
came, a father of one of
my classmates, and told us,
pointed out that Bandaids were
made for white skin tones.
So were Crayons,
so were hosiery.
That was what the
nude color was.
And once you know this,
you can't unsee it.
It changes you forever.
And this is why surfacing
these issues is so important.
A product that's designed and
intended for widespread use
shouldn't fail for an individual
because of something they
can't change about themselves.
Products and technology
should work for everyone.
The choices made in
those two examples
reinforce the
importance of being
thoughtful about technology
design and the impact it
might have on humans.
As in the case with
those two examples,
humans are at the center
of machine learning
and development.
And fairness concerns can easily
become embedded into AI product
design decisions.
So how can we approach
technologies to make
them more inclusive and fair?
Unfairness can enter into the
system at any point in the ML
pipeline--
here from data collection and
handling, to model training,
to end use.
In this typical view
of an ML pipeline,
you collect data, you label
the data, you train the model
and using certain objectives.
The data is packaged
and put into a product.
And users see the
effect and engage.
The way users engage informs
more data collection.
Within that pipeline,
the way we sample data,
the way we label it, how
the model is trained,
and whether or not the objective
leaves out a particular set
of users, how it was
packaged, and what kinds
of unconscious biases our
users bring engagement,
and how that affects,
how they behave,
and thus how we collect more
data can all work together
to create unfair biased systems.
Rarely can you identify a single
cause of or a single solution
to these problems.
Far more often, various
causes interact in ML systems
to produce problematic outcomes.
And a range of
solutions is needed.
The work of ML fairness is to
disentangle these root causes
and interactions and
find ways forward.
What's important is getting
clear on the questions
we need to answer.
There are a smattering
of questions
that can be used to
guide your fairness
work across the
pipeline, everything
from upfront product decision,
which is often under specified
in a lot of cases.
Really defining the
problem is all the way
to identifying if and when a
model isn't behaving correctly.
We want to know why
did the model fail.
Is the model trustworthy?
What are the limitations?
We've found these questions
to be helpful in guiding
our investigations.
Underlying all of this is
making sure the workforce is
inclusive.
The best way to make sure that
we, as teams, are equipped
is to have a diverse workforce
having these conversations.
Back to our pipeline-- at
each stage of this lifecycle,
we have identified tools,
best practices, and frameworks
to help ML practitioners
in their efforts
to build responsible AI.
At the start, we are looking
at problem definitions
and the resources we
have when we initially
qualitatively speak to
what we want to accomplish.
But when we talk about fairness,
some of the tools and resources
we have found valuable
here for fairness
are the stages at the
end of the ML lifecycle,
where we've really focused
in terms of tool development
and transparency frameworks in
the evaluation and monitoring
stages.
I want to move now
into some case studies
to show you some examples of
how this work has gone for us
and what we've done both
in the process of launching
products and evaluating
problems when they arose.
The first case study outlines
our approach in Cloud
to facial recognition and
how we got to this approach
through our principles
and the review
processes we've put into
place to operationalize them.
I'm going to start
with the outcome
of our in-depth review of
enterprise facial recognition
technology.
You can see here the
headline is the launch
of a tightly scoped API
called Celebrity Recognition,
available to professional media
and entertainment customers.
We launched this last fall.
You may realize that
video is all but
unsearchable without expensive
and labor-intensive tagging
processes.
This makes it really difficult
for creators and platforms
to organize their content
and cater to the increasing
demand for personalized
experiences,
or even to really understand
what content they have.
So Celebrity Recognition
is a pre-trained AI model,
which means it's
not customizable,
that is able to spot thousands
of popular actors and athletes
from around the world
based on licensed images.
This is Cloud's first
enterprise product
with facial recognition.
So I want to talk a
bit about the history.
In early 2016, Cloud
leadership decided
not to make facial
recognition available
as part of the Cloud
Vision API offering,
despite it being one
of the top requests
from customers coming out of
data which had started the year
before.
In 2017, facial recognition
was identified internally
as a key concern for
potential unfair bias
in our definition of
algorithmic unfairness, which
was written by our
Privacy and Security,
and now Responsible
Innovation and Privacy
colleagues, the core
definitional document
for Google's machine
learning fairness efforts.
We decided to take face
recognition through the process
we described earlier.
In mid-2020, just recently,
we welcomed the news
that other technology companies
were limiting or exiting
their facial
recognition business.
And this was thanks
significantly
to the gender sheets work,
which really informed
how this technology
can have impact
across a range of unfair biases
from skin tone to gender.
As you know, we decided not to
make a generally available face
recognition API available
because of our process
back in 2018.
So what we did,
initially within Cloud,
is an in-depth review of face
recognition technology by both
our dealer view and our
product review bodies,
as well as the central
Google executive council.
Our own internal
review processes
necessitated a broad look at
the research, societal context,
and complexities around
facial recognition.
Going through these processes--
and this was the second review
we ever did--
gave us the open
forum and the time
to really think critically
about the challenges.
And we realized that
alone we couldn't do this.
So we sought help
from third parties
to work with us on both external
benchmarking and performance.
And we began a human rights
due diligence process,
where we called
on domain experts,
and civil rights leaders,
and human rights leaders
that would allow us to
incorporate the perspectives
of impacted people.
Just a reminder of going back
to that conversation about how
our lived experience
is not going
to help us inform the
lives and perspectives
of impacted people.
And so it was really
important that we did the work
to understand that because
the reality is everything
we do, every product we
launch, every market we enter
does not exist in a vacuum.
And in order for us
to make decisions
that are aligned with
our AI principles,
we have to take this into
account at every step.
Technical analysis
alone is not enough
because the reality
is that there
is systematic societal
underrepresentation in media
of Black and minoritized actors.
And this needed to be the
basis for our evaluation.
As a side note, just
with the analysis
that the Geena
Davis Institute did
on gender, which showed
that women-led films made
16% more in the box office,
despite men being both seen
and heard twice as
much as women on film,
you can see that films with
racially diverse co-leads
had created 60% more in
gross income those films,
but were grossly
underrepresented in film
more broadly.
Human rights due diligence
became a core part
of what we needed to do.
Human rights are a basic code
of conduct for all human beings.
And we honor the universal
declaration of human rights
through the UN.
And so again, we really wanted
to seek external voices to help
us make this assessment.
And so we engaged in a process
called the Human Rights Impact
Assessment.
We did this through an
organization called BSR.
And BSR stands for Business
for Social Responsibility.
And they helped us to
really significantly improve
our product offering.
Engaging with BSR validated
many of our already planned
for alignment opportunities.
And we incorporated almost all
of their additional suggestions
across a range of
aspects of the product.
Their report is
publicly available.
And I encourage all
of you to read it.
All of this guidance
and the reviews
informed where we needed to
do our testing and fairness
analyses.
And it revealed to us
both where the solution
needed additional oversight
and validated the decision
not to offer a general purpose
facial recognition API.
So in the coming
slides, I'm going
to show you a deep dive into
the investigations that then
further informed the
product decisions we
made before launching.
So over three separate
fairness tests,
we found a discrepancy
in our training data
sets falling on skin tone
lines in one of those tests.
It's the one on the
right, the Eastwood v2.
This was obviously
very upsetting.
And just like we saw
earlier in the presentation,
for many organizations, this is
where they would have stopped
and said, we are just
not going to do this.
But because we knew that
we wanted to evaluate this
as thoroughly as we could, we
decided to take a deeper look.
The first thing we
had to determine
was if the skin tone
labels were accurate.
The answer was sort of.
They were not terribly
accurate in categorizing medium
and darker skinned people.
So based on the seminal work
and the findings of the Gender
Shade Study, we
categorized skin tone
into three buckets using the
Dermatological Fitzpatrick Skin
Type Scale, which is an estimate
of skin sensitivity to UV
radiation.
Going through labeling
the skin tones
resulted in a smaller
gap in the errors,
especially for the
medium skin tones.
But there was still a problem
in errors for the darker skin
tones.
So here are the results
of that relabeling.
25% of the skin tone
labels changed categories.
And it completely closed
the performance gap
with the medium
female skin tone.
So that then led us to the
additional discrepancies.
What we found was that
a very small subset
of actors and
actresses represented
a significant proportion of the
total missed identifications
in that evaluation data set.
And this was especially for
the dark skin tone groups
and especially for men.
So with that knowledge, that
a select few actors were
disproportionately affecting the
error rates in this data set,
we looked at those actors with
the largest number of errors
and found that they had nearly
a 100% false rejection rate.
Because we had made
the decision earlier
not to do a general
face recognition API,
but to take this
carefully scoped approach,
we were actually
able to go one by one
through the gallery and
the test set to determine
what the problem was.
So here's what we found.
It was really three actors
where our celebrity gallery had
images of those actors as
adults, while the Eastwood
training set had videos
of them much younger all
from the TV show
"Family Matters."
Our model could not
recognize the adult actors
as the younger characters they
had played many years prior.
In this instance, for our
celebrity recognition model,
we were able to correct that
problem by hand labeling, which
closed the gap completely.
And that is what allowed
us to get comfort
with launching this product.
But the answer
here is not to say
that this was an instance
of age in the images.
Because we took the time to
look at the larger landscape,
and we know the issues of
representation in media,
the fact that there
is a discrepancy
gave us pause to think
about what might actually
be happening here.
This is an example of why
this process is so important.
And these were some
of the headlines.
And in fact, this is
the BSR report as well.
But really, it's not
about slow walking.
It's about responsible
development of AI,
which is what leads to
successful deployment of AI.
None of this exists outside
of the larger landscape
we've looked at initially.
And it's because we started
with that understanding,
we were prepared to address it.
And we have to consider
that at every step.
Ethical AI is not only
about the extremes.
And it's not always
about AI for social good.
And it shouldn't be.
It's about being part
of every use case
where our job is to find
a path through extremely
complex and
intersecting realities.
This case study will show you
how we responded to two issues
with a generally available
product, which was our Google
Cloud Vision API.
Labeling is a
common practice used
to classify images and train
machine learning models
across many applications.
Labeling is core to
vision AI products.
And in 2019, we
identified an instance
that violated our AI principle
to avoid creating unfair bias.
Employees are our best
source of feedback.
And that is how we were
able to identify this issue.
A Googler ran an image
of themselves in the API,
returning a result
that misgendered them.
The Googler flagged this
to the Cloud Vision product
team, which set forth an
investigation into this issue.
Through the review and
assessment of this escalation,
it was important
to put this issue
in the context of the user
by identifying the cause
and effect this could have.
Gender misidentification, like
what happened to this Googler,
occurs because a person's
gender cannot be inferred based
on their physical appearance
by a human or model.
Their outward appearance
that the model uses
is not a determining factor
when assessing gender.
And the impact of doing
so exacerbates or creates
unfair assumptions
that restrict or harm
those who do not look
stereotypically male or female,
or who are a gender
nonconforming person.
The steps to evaluate
an escalation
are not always the same.
Some require in-depth product
testing, industry expertise,
third party
assessments, and so on.
Having identified the issue
that potentially harmful impacts
users, we formulated
a go-forward plan.
Reinforcing Google's commitment
to build products for everyone,
we made the decision that
a person's gender cannot be
inferred by appearance.
And attempting to do so
could perpetuate unfair bias.
Removing man and woman labels
from the Cloud Vision API
and replacing them with
a non-gender label,
such as person, is
the act we took.
Through this process, we
learned a couple key things
that altered our approach
to gendered label data.
There are often more
targeted signals
to attribute to a person
that provide more valuable
information to a customer.
Taking retail stores
as an example,
we might historically
analyzed foot traffic
with demographic information.
A more targeted labeling could
be a person's fashion sense
to analyze foot traffic
and cater their inventory
to those fashion types.
We also came to the
conclusion that,
when it comes to general tools
where we do not have control
over customer use cases,
to take a cautious approach
with capabilities
and functionality,
and build targeted
solutions where
we have a hand in the
development and use case.
The second example is the result
of an escalation of our Vision
API earlier this year, 2020.
And it shows how
important an understanding
of the societal context is
in which our products exist.
Here is the escalation.
You can see here, the
image with a Black person
and a handheld thermometer
returned a label for firearm.
And an Asian person holding
a handheld thermometer
returned a label for
electronic devices.
This was brought
to our attention
through the tweet you
see here on the left.
What happened next
was someone taking
a photo of the Black man
holding a thermometer gun
and manipulating to make the
skin appear to be lighter.
As you can see, this changed
the label from gun to tool,
which is a deeply
distressing result.
It is critical to recognize
why a result like this
can create increased harm.
The statistics here highlight
some of the societal context
in which this lives.
Any robust evaluation of this
escalation cannot separate this
reality of racial
justice, racial violence,
and systemic racism from
the technical analysis.
So what did we do?
Our investigations led
us across multiple teams.
And you can see here the
results of some of those.
Changing the skin tone
in the first example,
through some of our
counterfactual testing,
does change the
API's prediction.
But what we found was that
gun was still a top 5 label
response for all three
images in skin tones,
although API demo didn't
surface this result.
We used our own explanations
AI to look at saliency mapping.
Saliency maps for
the third hand images
show that the attributes
cluster predominantly
on the thermometer
for all three images
with some bleed into
the upper fingers
of the hand for the darker
and medium skin tone hands.
When we went into our
counterfactual testing further,
you could see that a change
of color of the thermometer
gun in the original
image also caused the gun
label to disappear.
We then did stability testing.
And in this case, the
image appears very
sensitive to image cropping.
Even minor variations make
that gun label disappear.
We also looked at
our training data.
We don't have many images of
handheld infrared thermometers.
And so this was a gap, as it's
a newer product in our own image
database.
And it's not
necessarily incorrect
that this be
labeled gun, as they
are called thermometer guns.
But if that's the
case, then they
should be labeled
that way unilaterally.
We found that many images
were mislabeled gun,
including things like
cameras, for example.
This example represents an
all hands on deck process
that required a humble
approach and thoughtful action
to remedy.
By conducting a detailed
assessment of the root
cause of this issue, we
were able to understand
that model accuracy and
stability were key drivers.
And by adjusting the
confidence threshold
to more precisely return labels
when a firearm is present,
we could greatly decrease
the chance of this happening
in the future.
This example showed
us, again, that we
have to do the work to put
the harm in context in order
to truly assess
the extent of it.
It isn't enough to say that this
was only about model accuracy
and stability because
this result was harmful.
And it exists in a world
of much larger harms
that we have to think about
when we address a problem.
What this taught us
through experience
was that none of
the evaluations we
do exist outside of the large
landscape and that context
in which they lived.
And that's the case for
every analysis we undertake,
for every product we launch,
for every decision we
make about how to best respect
our users, the opportunities,
and each other.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
I hope you've enjoyed
this conversation.
And I look forward to
many more in the future.